all right folks this shitshow saga of
the Korean League of Legends team that
won't stop exploding keeps getting
wilder this week we've got even more
allegations of abuse
we've got police reports and we've got
what might be a total overhaul of crazy
sports contracts this should keep
getting crazier so let's just get into
it all right so here comes my favorite
part of every Gryphon video the part
where I try to recap every video before
this one and hopefully we still have
enough time for a video after I'm done
Griffin is a league of Legends team
their coach CV max left abruptly before
worlds which kick started a chain of
insane events and including show the
team's a manager being outed for forcing
kanava
a minor into signing a contract that was
extremely unfair to him eventually we
learned that show and Griffin's
management allegedly tricked Kenobi's
parents into assigning a contract that
basically signed awaken Ava's right to
consent to being transferred to another
team this was allegedly part of a scheme
to pocket huge transfer fees for very
little investment then allegations began
to spread that CV max was verbally and
physically abusive to his players while
he was a coach on Griffin several
Gryphon players spoke to the media and
alleged that CV max said and did some
pretty crazy [ __ ] TV max defended
himself saying that his words were being
taken out of context and that he never
physically abuse anyone right also
Bancho and CD max though later they
suspended CB Max's ban and said they
were starting a third-party
investigation into the whole situation
after a Korean senator said that riot
could be punished for penalizing CB max
under some sort of Korean whistleblower
protection law so griffin let a bunch of
their players leave the org for free and
CB max has since joined up with a new
league of Legends team dragon axe the
investigation into his alleged abuse is
continuing but right now we have a new
development according to Korean news
site news 1 Griffin's top laner sword
has filed a police report against Evy
max alleging physical abuse this is as
far as we know the first time anyone has
gotten the cops involved in this whole
situation so it's a pretty big deal as a
quick refresher sword is one of the
players who spoke to invent and a qcu
max of verbal and physical abuse
he said that Stevie Max grabbed him by
the collar and shook him and then later
told him that he wasn't sorry for his
acts
and this is a direct quote from that
interview he also said that I'm
disgusting and that he can't handle me
he said that if we lose because of me
he'll follow me to the end of the world
to get revenge or that he'll kill me
according to a translation of that news
one article provided by invent swords
father said that once the team made it
to lck CV Max's coaching style got more
and more violent and he began insulting
players swords father also alleges that
CV max hit sword on the shoulder
threatened to kill him and caused so
much mental damage that sword and his
family have all started seeing a
psychiatrist the news article also
mentioned something really interesting
that isn't directly related to this case
they quote an anonymous games industry
official whatever that means
who said that the saga of coaching abuse
that began in baseball and winter sports
has finally made it to eSports so I
poked my head into that and apparently
in January Korea's Human Rights
Commission began investigating claims
that athletes were verbally physically
and occasionally sexually harassed by
their coaches I know this doesn't sound
super relevant but remember back when
this whole thing started a lot of people
into know who you know knew about the
Korean League of Legends community or
were part of it talked about how this
kind of verbally and physically
aggressive coaching style was pretty
common in Korea now while that doesn't
make it okay
it does tell us that coaches in Korea
may be used to operating in a way that
we in other parts of the world of you is
dangerous now players in Korea are
speaking up and saying that they're not
alright with that
which brings us to Stevie Max's defense
first news one reached out to him and he
told them that he and the players came
to an agreement about his coaching style
when it came to the verbal side of
things he also said that he never
physically assaulted or harassed any of
his players now Seanie max comes back to
that defense a lot like he said it and
pretty much all of his dreams and all of
his interviews he always says that he
and the players had some sort of
agreement and I really want to question
that because sure maybe they did talk
about it but like that's your coach he's
an authority figure he's basically your
boss and a bunch of kids who let's be
honest these League of Legends players
are very young they're sometimes minors
in the case of kanabi and otherwise
young children or young
they're not gonna necessarily fight him
they're just kind of gonna go with what
he says whether they like it or not well
the point is whatever relationship they
had it wasn't exactly balanced things
were pretty heavily in CD Max's favor as
an authority figure
so whatever agreement they came to I
don't know if it really holds up you
know then cv max took to his stream and
clarified things further so right now
we're working off a translation posted
to Twitter by a user named Raptor so
thanks to them for doing this CD max
stated that swords claims of assault are
lies he also alleged that sword was
mixing up his story between strangling
and hitting and I'm gonna be real I
actually hadn't seen any mentions of
swords saying that he was strangled but
CJ Mack says that that happened at some
point see to max also alleged that
swords parents were calling the parents
of other Gryphon players to find out if
they were physically and verbally
harassed now the way that he said this
on stream was allegedly like they were
on a witch hunt for him but that sounds
pretty reasonable to me actually he also
said that Viper one of the Gryphon
players who actually stuck with a team
sent him a message of support saying
that he missed the good old days but of
course nobody provided any publicly
available evidence to any of their
claims allegedly riot has a recording of
CV max verbally abusing his players but
they haven't released that which means
beyond hearing those recordings we have
no way of knowing who's right or wrong
until that third party investigation is
completed so let's do a quick recap of
what we have from both sides sword says
that he was verbally and physically
assaulted by CB max cv max countered by
saying that while he may have gone too
far verbally at times he and the players
came to an agreement and everything was
cool also P denies any physical abuse
whatsoever while riot has said that that
third party investigation into cv max's
actions will be transparent and open we
actually haven't heard any updates from
it so it's not feeling super transparent
right now but there is one more
interesting piece of news to come out of
all of this and shockingly it has
nothing to do with the whole abuse side
of this scandal do you guys remember
Qaddafi he was the player he was a minor
who was coerced into signing a contract
that basically made him sign all of his
rights away including the right to
consent to being transferred to another
team well it turns out that
a lot of League of Legends players were
on contracts that were also pretty rough
just like his so senator take yong-ha
who was looking into the whole situation
basically forced KeSPA the government
supported a body that oversees esports
in korea to draft a new standard
contract for esports players in korea
the issue is that the new contract they
drafted kind of [ __ ] sucked
the new contract was allegedly worse
than any of the old Gryphon contracts
with some pretty insane causes including
one that allowed teams to take in any
prize money players earn from venue fees
or prize winnings just anything at all
and they could distribute it to that
player as they saw fit with absolutely
no oversight they were also able to fire
a player if that player ever spoke to
the media which crazy and bad for me oh
also the new standard contract had a
clause in it they'll let teams transfer
players to other teams without their
consent and if that sounds familiar
that is the exact clause that was in
Griffin's contract with Konami that kick
started this whole mess in the first
place like if you're trying to draft a
new shitty contract that is bad for
players and it we used to leave out the
one clause that started the whole
problem like how do you [ __ ] up this bat
you had one job to do so senator ha is
now calling on everyone between KeSPA
the teams involved warriors riot
everybody to get together in a room and
hash out a new contract that is fair to
players but the news that the new
standard contract sucks kick-started a
new investigation this time by the
Korean Fair Trade Commission they're now
looking into Korean eSports contracts in
general and hopefully they can enact
some real change here because apparently
no one knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
so basically what all that means is that
crane eSports contracts are probably
gonna change forever likely in ways that
benefit players more than they do right
now that is likely gonna cause huge
changes in the Korean eSports industry
at large in ways that honestly I don't
think I'm super qualified to speculate
on but what I do know for sure is that
we're gonna keep updating you on this
totally insane story and as soon as we
hear some new info we'll let you know
about it
that was so much it was I've like
drenched in hand sanitizer now dripping
wonderful can you give me a less hand
sanitizer this time like it's dripping
yeah I was like dripping on the floor
I'm like alright Matt no I wouldn't say
it's drip